okay hello and welcome to your party
global 2021 my name is zachary i'm
really happy to be here and be your host
for this session
i would like to now welcome april to our
session
and she will talk about the
that's from poc to production and april
has been developed software in finance
for over 15 years she has extensive
experience in designing and defining
data platform and data intensive
application from investment banking and
investment fund
it will need the research data science
platform at our capital providing with
researchers with the last technology and
technical in data expo
it's it's analysis calculation and
visualization so let's
move the time to april thank you
i make you as a coho again okay there we
go all right tactical challenge is over
thank you everyone apologies for those
uh those challenges uh so my name is
april rathey as zach said and i'm
excited to be here today to take you
through our journey as we took gas from
poc to production
i am the head of the research data
science platform at arrow street capital
where i lead a team of quant developers
aerostreet capital is a quantitative
investment firm in boston
and our goal is to generate sustainable
alpha which means returns in excess of a
benchmark for institutional investors
primarily pension funds
we do this primarily through investment
in global equity strategies
in order to achieve achieve sustainable
alpha we constantly go through
innovation cycles so the research team
is responsible for looking for
information that is highly relevant to
price yet less obvious to other instant
other investors
in order to support this we need
technology and so my team's
responsibility is to identify integrate
and build technologies to make those
research innovation cycles faster and
easier which brings us to desk so a
brief recap of das this information is
taken from the desk website and there's
loads of information available there as
well as talks available and explaining
what it is but i'll point out the key
features from our perspective
the first is that dask is written in
python so it's a distributed computing
framework a parallelization framework
that integrates natively with the pi
data stack
it provides interfaces that are familiar
to people who are used to working with
numpy arrays and pandas data frame
objects
and it provides two levels of
parallelization in terms of apis you can
do it implicitly where there's
parallelization built into data frame
array and beg objects when you're using
them
or you can do it explicitly where you
define the task graph where you define
the partitioning strategy and you can
use das delayed in futures
the other core feature of dasc which we
found key to our use case was that it
was really built for interactive use
and that manifests itself in a number of
ways but one of those that we find
really useful is the ability to run
desks locally on a local cluster and
then when ready remotely on a
distributed cluster when you're ready to
gain additional compute capacity
the context of this particular work that
we undertook was that we really liked
using gas globally we had started using
it individually and on one of projects
but we wanted to expand it as a tool to
be used across our entire research team
easily that meant seamlessly switching
from local to remote clusters having
user or job dedicated clusters that we
could really create from anywhere and
seamlessly switch between those
different contexts
the challenges that then emerged as part
of this goal
was really focused on four areas
hardware
the stack of technologies that we needed
to learn and how we could make that easy
how we would access data and which task
apis mapped best to our use cases
which takes us to the scope of this talk
which is to walk through the five stages
that we undertook
as we walked through expanding the use
of desk to our entire team
we started first with our use cases
which i think is essential for any
technology project thinking about where
your constraints are what capabilities
you're trying to achieve so that you can
make the best technical and
architectural decisions
we identified three use cases for das
the first was exploratory research so
this is where we're working with new
vendor data sets trying to find new
information either
in any of the structures of data that we
might have either in a set that we've
already got where there's existing
attributes we're not using or in totally
new data sets that we're exploring
we often start initially working with
smaller data sets but then quickly want
to expand our analysis once we have an
idea that we think might work
we often also merge results so we need
to integrate it with existing data sets
or existing metrics to get a feel for
how they compare
the second use cases are our simulations
this is where we're doing what-if
analysis asking questions like what if
this portfolio existed how would it have
performed over the whole history
of our investments or if we changed
these configurations or these toggles on
our systematic investment process what
would happen
and so these tend to be path dependent
calculations where the output of one
task is an input to the next and are
kind of complicated in order to
parallelize
the third use case are historical data
processing requirements and we do this
for a number of reasons two of which are
backfills we have a new idea we'll want
to back populate that all the way back
as far as the data exists and the second
is to incorporate restatements so we'll
get updates from our vendors we then
need to incorporate those and reflect
those in our computations
out of these three use cases emerge
three computation patterns
those that are embarrassingly parallel
and easily partitioned by constructs
like date
those that are path dependent which
require the output of the previous task
as an input to the next task
and processes that are combination and
bring these two things together in order
to complete
we also wanted to think about where we
wanted to run the computations from so
this is an important input into the
infrastructure decisions that you may
make we wanted to run them from on from
our desktops right for our exploratory
use cases where we're using pycharm or
vs code or notebooks as well as from our
scheduled or systematic processes which
could be in aws running a server
services or on our on-prem servers and
it was key that there was a minimal
change required to change between those
contacts we didn't have to rewrite code
we wanted to really do it as much
through configuration as possible
so understanding those constraints those
use cases we moved immediately on to our
cluster infrastructure
which i think if you look at some of the
documentation and literature you'll see
that this is really one of the most
challenging parts of the process
and so for us we stepped back first and
just described what did we want to
achieve what did we want to work
and we defined really an ephemeral stack
we wanted everything created on demand
and isolated so that there was no
resource contention
or scheduling needed in order to decide
who would win
in order to get the resources that we
wanted so we wanted ephemeral hardware
as well as gas clusters with burst
capacity to respond to whatever request
we needed minimal startup time for that
cluster
the ability to apply both templated as
well as custom resource specifications
and because we had ephemeral
requirements we needed cost transparency
attribution and automatic cleanup of all
of those resources right so we needed to
make sure we didn't have runaway costs
so we made some early decisions we knew
we were gonna have to use a cloud
provider to provide first capacity and
we went with aws because this aligned
with some of the other efforts we had
underway
we knew we would need a resource manager
so we decided to look at both kubernetes
and hpc
and most importantly we knew this would
have to be a collaborative effort it
wasn't something that we could do just
within research uh just within the quant
dev team we needed help from our central
infrastructure teams our cloud
infrastructure teams our research
systems teams and so we were able to
come up with this collaborative effort
of teams and skills across the
organization to make this happen
we started first with our container
service options and looking at what we
could use including batch ecs and eks
desk doesn't care um so we started out
thinking that das could have an opinion
around this but it doesn't um it can
really run on any infrastructure and any
container service option that you choose
and so we decided to align this with our
internal decisions some other projects
and processes that we had
underway and to really lean into the
open source community and the kubernetes
options that were available
and so we went with eks
even though it was more complex and had
you know more challenges and kind of
running it and keeping it going it gave
us more flexibility and because we had
some of the resources and experiences
internal to our teams we were
comfortable with that decision and the
long-term flexibility we would gain from
doing that
we then looked at our compute layer
options fargate and ec2 where our
considerations were really around
startup time and flexibility
we went with ec2 because we didn't want
any constraints around the resource
profiles that we would be able to
leverage we wanted to be able to use
gpus we wanted to have any size memory
or cpus and we didn't want any limits on
our scaling requirements so if we have
lots of researchers coming at one time
who want to use their own clusters they
can do so without stepping on one
another
which resulted in a setup of us having
eks on top of ec2 where we then
leveraged another
a set of concepts within aws in order to
fulfill the requirements that we defined
we use aws accounts for separation
between our ad hoc and our scheduled use
cases to ensure that there was no
accidental uh impact from our
user driven requests on our schedule or
production processes
we use namespaces then within those
accounts to give us that isolation of
user or job so that the hardware the
infrastructure is all per request and we
allow for multiple per user
we use aws auto scaling groups per ec2
instance type and you can see here just
some of those names right so i can have
the c5x large and i can have as many
nodes as i want spun up in terms of ec2
instances
we use tagging for cost visibility at a
number of levels to allow us to slice
and dice alert and report later on
we use clis that exists in the open
source community around kubernetes for
investigations wherever possible we use
elk for logging so that our logs persist
across clusters and we don't have to
keep the clusters around to understand
what happened and then we use s3 for
data so that we have the scalability
required to respond to large numbers of
workers when they spin up
this illustrates what the cluster life
cycle looks like when a user requests a
new cluster
we start first with mapping an ad user
to an iam role and a kubernetes role so
we can lean into kubernetes security
we then immediately create the namespace
container setting up security and
networking
we then use aws auto scaling groups for
creating the nodes those nodes are then
allocated or assigned to that namespace
and join the cluster
and then on top of that we create our
kubernetes deployment including our
ingress certificate the services and
certificates
deletion is then triggered by one of two
events either close the cluster or the
harvester terminates it due to an
inactive period in either scenario it
deletes all of the resources the
deployments the nodes the node groups as
well as the name space so that there are
no resources that exist post the
specific use or request
and this is just a view then on what it
looks like across accounts and users on
the left you can see the production
account where it has a service account
connecting from one of our production
services and creating its name space for
its specific job and then on the right
you can see the ad hoc account where
different users can come in and request
one or more namespaces with their own
node groups with their own
ec2 instance types that live for the
life of their request
so with the hardware decisions made the
next thing we had to do was figure out
what the das integration would be on top
of that
so our challenge was really to ensure
that we were creating and using desk
interfaces that minimized the barrier
for use just made it easy
but also allowed for expert user
customization later on once everyone had
really gotten to that expert level over
time
it needed to integrate with our eks and
aws infrastructure for cluster creation
ensure that all the connections were
secure between the cluster and clients
and then easily allow us to transition
between that use of a local and remote
cluster
we looked at the options out there dasc
is a very rich community in terms of
packages and libraries and options
unfortunately none of these fit are used
exactly um there's a very interesting
kind of use of of you know which ones
deal with hardware versus which ones
just deal with deploying um the cluster
dash cluster on top of existing hardware
and what the security assumptions are um
under each of these libraries and so
none of them were exactly what we needed
but they gave us a lot of inspiration
and allowed us to understand how other
people were approaching the problem
we ended up building a custom python
module in cli on top of our aws
constructs to manage our namespaces node
groups and nodes we use photo3 for aws
service interactions and the kubernetes
api for interacting with eks and
deploying our kubernetes deployments
this module automatically ensures that
we apply security name spacing and
tagging to our clusters ensures that the
harvester is set up to look for those
inactive clusters that should be taken
down and allows us to apply our
parameterized customized uh
kubernetes deployments in order to
create our gas clusters on top of that
hardware
we then extended
our the das distributed cluster to
provide our cluster interface and it
really just sets up an injection point
for us to interact with that underlying
module it allows us to use our templates
so we like to use templates as much as
possible and then allow for overrides
it calculates the number of ec2
instances based on those parameters and
then ensures that our client environment
matches our cluster environment or our
worker environment by setting up some
standard conventions
we also extended the desk client
which just again gives us an injection
point an abstraction point to set our
security contacts consistently and
register any default worker plugins
and here below you can see an example
and it looks very familiar because it
looks just like the desk documentation
the das interfaces are very nice to use
they're easy to extend they're easy to
add your own customizations wherever you
need and they're very thin um so neither
of these extensions are our large code
bases um they're pretty straightforward
they were relatively easy to write but
they give us that nice injection point
to work with going forward and here at
the bottom you can see obviously first
you know the number of kind of different
customizations around templates and
parameterization options we expose
and then using the client looks just
like again all the documentation that
you see out there which means we can
still lean on and use and leverage all
the work that people have put into the
desk community
so the final stage which is one i think
that people don't often get to in a lot
of the documentation and examples that
are out there is to think about data
access
you know it changes the minute you want
to be able to access it in a number of
different contexts from a number of
different scalability levels you can run
into trouble and so we wanted to ensure
that this was really easy and that data
access didn't become a blocker when we
wanted to use desk in one of our
processes
so our challenge was to think about how
we could use das to access data sets
that existed really in our existing
formats we didn't want to have to
re-format or re-platform our data in
order to be able to use das
our data is primarily in files on nfs
on-prem today so we knew we needed a
single interface that would allow us to
access files
on-prem and in aws uh that it would work
for both a local cluster and a remote
cluster that we would need to think
about our data partitioning strategies
in those files whether the files were
big stacked files or already partitioned
by a construct like date
and then we needed to think about the
data interfaces both interrupt process
so within a single process how was data
exchanged and now that das was in the
mix there's pickling that can go on so
communication between the client and the
cluster as well as between the workers
in the cluster for data sharing
as well as our inter process so where we
have a scheduled process that's part of
a wider chain we didn't want to have to
change the inputs or outputs or have
those be affected we wanted those
interfaces to stay the same
so we built a number of modules to just
make this seamless and again this was
leveraging a number of constructs in the
open source community already we built a
model a module to help with
synchronization just to allow us to
easily move data back and forth from um
our local shares to s3 using s3fs and
voteo3
we also built a datastore module that
allows us to through configuration and
environment setup seamlessly switch
between s3 and local data stores
we also have the ability to override
that so you can say go to the specific
data store and we support a read through
read fall through precedence so that
people don't have to hunt around for
files it will simply choose the best one
based on a precedence definition
and then we also implemented a pandas i
o extension that allows us to do read
and write
seamlessly interacting with that data
store so again it's all just set up
automatically for our users
you can see here at the top some
examples of how we've got these
definitions around data store names
there's read data stories there's right
data stores they can be different
if you don't specify a data store and
you're just doing a pdx using our
extension and doing a write or read on a
data frame it uses your environment
configuration which was local when i did
this
but you can also override it and here's
a case of where i went to s3 instead and
it just uses the same interfaces with
very little effort on our
so we had everything in place we were
really excited we were ready to start
rolling gas out to the team more widely
so we thought very uh i thought a lot
about how we would do that how we would
make it easy for people to get going and
we decided that the best way it is
really to provide examples to integrate
it into three processes and so we chose
them based on two dimensions the first
being runtime we wanted to have the
biggest impact possible in terms of the
critical path of some of our processing
chains and we wanted to demonstrate
different desk integration patterns so
that we could help people see the ways
that you could use das
our first example was easy to choose um
it was already using das as a local
cluster and it was embarrassingly
parallel task so it was the larger the
memory data set the files were
partitioned by date and all we had to do
was switch from using uh the client
directly with a local cluster default
to using our rec cluster with the right
specification and over here you can see
the task graph which is very boring it's
a single list of tasks all run in
parallel
that then is executed
the next two examples were a bit more
interesting um example two was using the
data frame so this was really
excellent to demonstrate to people how
easy it was to use it you simply switch
to using the dash data frame instead of
pandas but we had to do a rewrite
because of the type of processing that
we were doing which had a lot of group
buys a lot of repartitioning
based on the structure of the
computation and we were able to leverage
data frame with mathematicians and set
index in order to implement this
computation
and then the third example was one of
those combined examples and these are
really the trickiest ones so the ones
where steps have to be done serially and
then other steps can be done in parallel
again it needed a major rewrite to group
those types of processes together and it
was a multi-stage process where we did
some locally on the client side some on
desk and then brought data back together
again that was built using gas delayed
in terms of results um we were able to
achieve really good speed ups um and i
think these three examples nicely
demonstrated some of the flexibility we
gain right so we can choose different
ec2 instance types per job we can use
different numbers of instances different
numbers of task workers we have
different costs because of that and we
can gain different speed ups based on
the profile of the process that we're
looking at
the final step of the rollout was really
ensuring that we provided cost
transparency so we wanted to just kind
of give people the flexibility to do
what they needed to do with no
constraints and no barriers but to do
that safely we also needed to give
information provide visibility on what
you're about to do so that you aren't
surprised at the end by what you ended
up doing uh so we provide cost
transparency in three ways to the
research team as we're using it the rec
cluster upon creation reports back an
estimated cost per hour so this is
really useful because you know what
you're doing you kind of can watch the
clock ticking a little bit and you know
what you're running up in terms of cost
so there's no real surprise bill then at
the end
the second are reports so we're able to
slice and dice by the tags that we've
added to our infrastructure things like
user name space and job to do real
attribution
down to a very low level around where
our costs are being driven from
and then finally we've set up a number
of email alerts just to give visibility
when people are approaching some targets
or some thresholds or limits that we've
set these aren't hard limits they aren't
intended to stop people from using
whatever they need to complete the
projects that they're working on but
it's about giving that visibility right
letting people know what is about to
happen
that concludes my talk for today and i
think zac you're about to give me notice
of five minutes so that's great timing
um if this work is interesting if
anybody has questions feel free to reach
out to me directly there's my email
address as well as the website for and
linkedin profile for arrow street yes
thank you april perfect time
i worked on that
okay there's a i got a question from
phillip
um he's asking i would like to know
whether one could use that's deleted
object over that data from
this kind of structure be allowed
by desk
yeah so this is this idea of the
different ways that you can use das and
i think this is one of the great
features of das right it has desk data
frame which just operates like a pandas
data frame
most features and options are supported
it's pretty close um and it means you
don't have to understand what's
happening how the parallelization is
happening it's just done for you so it's
really implicit desk delayed then is
where you know let's say you were doing
a loop across dates right i'm going to
go through and i'm going to calculate
this for every single date um that would
be a case where you could use das
delayed right you're doing manual
partitioning you're defining the
partitioning by something like date and
you have a collection of these tasks
that can then be executed you've defined
a task graph
and so both use cases are fantastic they
just fit different patterns of what
you're trying to do and so for us
delayed fits really nicely with these
embarrassingly parallel or partitioned
types of work that you can do
and das data frame fits better with our
path dependent processing where we want
to optimize really every single path
computation and we could then leverage
data frame underneath to do that for us
okay so thank you another question is
what were the biggest challenge
introducing deck to users who like
pandas
yeah that's a great question you know i
think
at the end of the day there's still
complexity so we've we've created all
these interfaces we've created all these
layers and when things go well and there
aren't problems it's great you don't
even know what's going on you just gain
this kind of magic capacity um but when
things go wrong
when things stop working um it can be
hard to unpick why right so you can get
things like these features exceptions
coming out of task what does that mean
what happened which layer of the stack
actually had a problem
and so i think you know again it's great
we give it to people they can start
working with it and then gradually
they'll hit errors
and that's where we'll train them about
how to deal with that and so we're kind
of able to do this very layered learning
approach um but that's the hardest part
like at the end of the day there are
still a lot of layers there are a lot of
things that can go wrong there's a lot
of moving parts a lot of moving pieces
um and so you can't completely abstract
that away especially in cases of errors
where something didn't work the way you
expected it to do
okay
so
last question from brian um do your
researchers use judith hope running
within your k a s
crypto running locally with a remote
connection
yes we don't currently use jupiter hub
um that's something that we're kind of
looking at is one of the next things we
want to do right now if people are using
notebooks they're just running them
locally
on their desktops
okay we still have some time we get one
motion um for single machine research
how important was to was it to turn the
desk
configuration on your machine did it
just work out of the boss
yeah we didn't have to do
much das
configuration um you know most of it it
does work just out of the box until you
get into some very specific
use cases of very specific requirements
um and so i think it is one of those
things as with a lot of libraries is
that you start with the defaults um you
then hit errors or hit kind of cases of
problems and figure out which ones you
need to tune around that but you know
out of the box it it does
work um and it works for most cases that
you're starting to work with um
generally
okay thank you april our time is over
could you kindly move the discussion to
the snack or get a ton
and thank you so much april to talk for
being part of the pie leader google 2021
thank you so much thank you